I like the Bombardier [ __ ] pilot
to Bombardier Tuesday were going deep
today
what's happening you bad [ __ ]
uncle Joey here Tuesday October 18 your
swinging dick and giving our bubble gum
you understand me you ain't got time to
[ __ ] and cry you ain't got time to think
about the election because you think
that thinking about you so cut this [ __ ]
who gives a [ __ ] about all this they're
not worried about you all you got to
worry about is how you're gonna pick up
a [ __ ] envelope - that's it plain and
[ __ ] simple how am i what and what do
I need to do to stick it in somebody's
[ __ ] muffler today that's that's the
only thing you take it away you don't
give a [ __ ] about that else you know
you're not worried about money you
worried about right [ __ ] it now today
how am I gonna pick up an envelope today
well uncle Joey's here to [ __ ] tell
you but before we get the party started
you know us we got a [ __ ] meditate a
little bit smoked couple numbers deep
man on the podcast last Ralphie may reef
or edibles you know how we [ __ ] do it
listen there's never a dull moment with
uncle Joey you understand me
you people is [ __ ] sleeping and we're
over here I'm creepy oh my goodness we
got this Paris og again the [ __ ] it's
just killing [ __ ] you
understand
yeah I won't even say listen I can't
take it no more even your hide walls
like I can't take a moment
look at that right there
that's a [ __ ] cloud of debt if I ever
saw one you're sitting there doubting
yourself what the [ __ ] am I gonna do
today I don't know they're not gonna
like me who gives a [ __ ] they don't like
you they don't lead to like you little
[ __ ] that needs to like you is
you [ __ ] something everybody else just
suck your dick that's not like they
listen nobody likes me I know that going
in I don't give a Frenchman's [ __ ] I
gotta be me [ __ ] nobody could stop you
you understand me Joey what's with the
chitter chatter spark that [ __ ] soul
none like sitting back and let the fumes
of [ __ ] life take over your brain let
you know you ain't [ __ ] around today
that's the most important thing you
ain't got time to [ __ ] oh did you watch
The Simpsons last night I don't give a
[ __ ] about the Simpsons okay I give a
[ __ ] about life [ __ ]
oh the inner light gets turned on you
understand me I got a big day today
every day's a [ __ ] big day when
you're six feet above I don't give a
[ __ ] of you just gonna sit there and
stare at the sky and wait for a [ __ ]
pigeon to fall out every day is a big
day cause you're alive you swing and dig
your polish in that [ __ ] helmet they
can't stop you even if you [ __ ] give
up they can't stop the understanding you
always want to be the [ __ ] underdog I
was born on the dog I don't give a [ __ ]
jack I take that umbilical cord and
choke your [ __ ] with it I'm still
smoking reefer what am I talking about
even though it's [ __ ] Tuesday I'm
stoned to the gills I got a big day I
got a big night and that's all that
[ __ ] madness I got the family the
sun's out it's gonna be [ __ ] eighty
degrees today a hundred on [ __ ]
Thursday so you know you tell me what
the [ __ ] is really going on
one of Vegas Halloween weekend
Southpoint casino tickets are up from in
Boston November 11th and Foxwoods casino
and November 12 are you [ __ ] kidding
me oh are you kiddin take the fight I
don't give a [ __ ]
beside this [ __ ] Flo I need to
check from a commercial this is a
completely different situation here this
will [ __ ] you up I'm [ __ ] up around I
already have my almond smoothie milk I
have my little [ __ ] protein shake at
10:00 and then I see what the [ __ ]
happens I got a meeting I might just go
to jujitsu just to do hip escape today
I'm loosening up my back with some blood
and that [ __ ] back I need this [ __ ] I
can feel the fatness from the inside
it's over I gotta get my [ __ ] together
oh yeah well he met another completely
sorry but it was a bit didn't get my
Michael I'm all wrong I am painting
there's one word more wrong dies when
you really want to drop some [ __ ]
knowledge on these people you gotta drop
him off from down on them from time to
time that means a big [ __ ] dick with
whipped cream on boy it emit lot more
from they have wrote that Gullu I will
say Baja that's me just [ __ ] around
I'm stunned to see the Spanish of
[ __ ] shock tones you don't say the
world will come out tomorrow whatever
something about reefer in the morning
makes me wanna jump out of [ __ ]
window you understand me now I'm covered
ain't got a job I've no [ __ ] window
I'm just I take revenge on life and take
the notebook I have lined the book we
should have this last chapter up myself
and [ __ ] pardon
at this time next year you'll be reading
the [ __ ] book about uncle Joey I'm
sensing the muggings the whole [ __ ]
deal all right besides that you know I
love you [ __ ] I got your back you
know why cuz you got my back and I
[ __ ] know that
I know people around here I walk around
when I see they ain't got my back but my
[ __ ] soldiers of death on Church have
my [ __ ] back and I got your back
number I'm with you right with me you're
with me and they want to be with us but
they can do that yeah well it'll be
doing go Joe what the [ __ ] you think you
do you grab your pants you sharpen your
knife and you don't look [ __ ] back
and if you can't do that will [ __ ] you
so like I said the church is up we'll be
back come on I'm mad tonight I'm gonna
go do some things and then that's it
I'll see you [ __ ] tomorrow night
maybe tomorrow morning we'll chitchat a
little bit I'm stoned today girls you
know how it goes sometimes you just get
too [ __ ] high in the morning and you
gotta do what you gotta do
you guys know when my heart is ever I'm
with you kind of suck just don't take
[ __ ] from nobody today sling dick with
both hands remember at the end of the
day they all suck your dick right uncle
Joey got you down load do what you need
to do I'll see you in Vegas I love you
touched up to stay black don't take [ __ ]
from nobody today it's Tuesday I didn't
get my Martin our bingo or your ayah I
see I said it